I'm just going to hit something off at the pass right here.
V Person We're covering in today's video has a Mongolian name.
It's an old Mongolian named.
We're not really even sure how it would be pronounced,
and I'm certainly not Mongolian,
so I'm just going to go with [inaudible].
I looked up some videos on youtube that seems to be a sort of accepted western
pronunciation.
It's what I'm going with.
If you really want to,
you can have a go at me in the comments.
So the Mongolian empire,
his rhythm is for that Bob Barrick conquests and the power of their great
leaders that managed to spread the embargo across several continents.
But one of the most fascinating people that has been forgotten from the empire
is the warrior princess could her urine.
She was the great,
great granddaughter of Gangas Con,
and she truly inherited his strength battle.
Unlike many other princesses and queens throughout the history of the wells,
Cotto was remembered for her own glory rather than the achievements of a husband
or a son,
or she may just have been the strongest Mongolian warrior of all time.
And in this week's biographics her life.
Yeah.
Before we get into the details about the life of Kotor Yoon,
it's important to go over some of the details of the Mongolian empire.
For thousands of years,
various tribes in Mongolia,
it went to war with one another and they were never your nightmares.
Under one single government plans and horses were taken as spoils of war.
Women and children were seen as the property of men and they were used as
trophies of conquest.
Powerful men had more than one wife and chief Danes typically had a harm.
Genghis Khan became the first leader to unite all of Mongolia.
He achieved this by training his army to be masterful warriors that were
stronger than many other army in the world.
They trained falcons to send messages and communicate with one another,
which helps him to spread his army over vast territories.
He pushed his men to train harder to become a new breed of super warrior.
Genghis Khan once said,
I man's greatest pleasure is do defeat his enemies to drive them before him,
to take from them that which they possessed,
to see those whom they cherished in tears,
to ride their horses and to hold their wives and daughters in his arms.
Angus,
Colin's army was so strong they were able to defeat the tribe is one by one.
After uniting Mongolia,
he set his sights much farther than his own country.
He wanted to become the ruler of the entire world.
He took over parts of Asia,
the Middle East,
and Europe.
It became the largest empire in the history of humanity.
Even though their army was known for being ruthless warriors,
the Mongolian Empire actually brought a lot of innovations to the world during
times of peace.
They were tolerance if religions.
They encouraged international trade and they were known for that diplomacy.
Ganga is column.
It had several wives of his own and he had many,
many children.
His grandson,
Kublai Khan became the ruler of Mongolia in the year 1260 and his brothers and
cousins held positions of power all over the empire.
Unfortunately,
if Kublai Khan,
he was not as feared as his great grandfather hood.
One spin spinner,
Mongolia woods eventually begin to break off into civil wars.
Kublai Khan would even go to war with his own brother.
AREC book.
A man named kid was Kublai Khan's cousins.
He was the leader of the house.
If they die,
the two cousins disagreed with one another on house and run the end buyer in
this,
which eventually caused them to go to war as well.
Kid who had 14 sons,
but his favorite child by far was his daughter [inaudible],
an Italian explorer record.
Marco Polo wrote down the history of the Mongolian empire whilst living amongst
Kublai Khan's.
Raul caught most of what is known about humans.
Life came from his books as well.
There's some comments made by a Persian statesman named Rashid al Din.
She was called by several names,
including [inaudible],
which translates to shining moon.
While this is a beautiful name to give to a baby girl,
she would grow up to prove that she was far from a dainty princess.
Okay.
Uh,
because of getting his cons legacy for future generations of Mongolian warriors,
we're trained to be some of the strongest people on the planet.
If they wanted the Mongolian Empire to stretch across the globe,
they needed to be prepared to take down any enemy.
By the age of two,
boys were already learning how to shoot bows and arrows and ride on horseback.
They wrestled one another to learn hand to hand combat.
They practiced both the Chinese martial arts of Kung Fu as well as ancient
Mongolian fighting techniques.
They weren't just doing all of this training on foot either.
All of their fighting techniques also needed to be executed while riding at high
speeds on horseback.
This included both wrestling and archery.
Because of this,
the enemies would always and never be able to knock a Mongolian off of his horse
no matter how hard they tried in Mongolia,
horses are a huge part of that culture.
The number of horses actually outnumbers the human population.
People,
late horse masons,
they drank mare's milk.
This milk was actually fermented into an alcoholic beverage,
which is considered to be the national drink of Mongolia.
To this very day.
There is a saying,
a Mongol without a horse is like a bird without the wings.
While all of this training,
fighting and partying was normal for boys,
it was always never taught to girls.
Women were expected to be delicate and subservient to men while they took care
of the farming,
the child rearing and various household tasks.
Qt Unit,
it was a Tom boy since she was young and she wanted to practice fighting with
the boys far more than she was willing to dance or play with dolls.
It is record of his adventures.
Marco Polo describes could have Yoon as looking statuesque.
She was so tall.
One might mistake her for a giant test.
Since the members of the royal family always chose the most beautiful women in
the country to take as their wives.
She would have also been very pretty most likely looking like a modern day
supermodel.
But unlike most princesses,
cuter union isn't remembered for looks.
She was known for her incredible wrestling skills.
You could say that she was the world's first celebrity female wrestler long
before the ages of glow in the WWE.
She was so ahead of our time.
It would take hundreds of years after our death before female wrestling would
even be an acceptable sport around the world.
Mongolian style wrestling is very different from what you see on TV or even what
you saw in your high school.
There was no separation of weight class just to people lock arms and they try to
push each other over in many way.
They can imagine arm wrestling and he using your entire body to push the other
person down to the grounds.
Once the opponent is knocked to the floor of the person who remained standing is
the winner.
Because of this,
the person's physical strength usually determines who the victim will be.
Couldn't even practice wrestling and continue to get stronger every day.
She was seen better than any man she had ever gone up against and she had the
goal of becoming the strongest wrestler in the world.
When she was old enough to get married,
several suitors began to show interest and making have that wife,
her father,
king kid begins,
you prepass them eligible suitors for hat could have done,
was not afraid to speak her mind to her father and to rebelliously announced
that she could never marry a man unless he was able to defeat her in a wrestling
match.
At that time,
even princes were not usually able to choose who that wife would be.
Politics trumped falling in love and his marriages where usually meant to keep
peaceful ties across the empire,
but since she showed so much strength,
Chi do gave his daughter his word that she would be free to marry any man of her
choosing and official proclamation was written and spread across the end buyer
announcing that his daughter was looking for her husband.
As long as he defeated in wrestling,
the entry fee was a hundred horses.
If they lost,
they'd have to forfeit their horses to the House of Aga dye,
which would only increase the wealth and power of their army.
Despite the facts,
there's horses a such a huge part of Mongolian culture.
People usually only had one or two per hell souls.
If they were lucky.
Owning a hundred horses was no simple task.
A man would have had to come from some kind of inability to even collect to the
entry fee.
We know there's at least 100 men showed up at the house.
If all get it to challenge to you into a match because she connected a fleet of
over 10,000 horses.
It's safe to assume that many of these men who came to win the match where
probably the feeling overly confidence before they arrived,
they probably felt the defeating and princess would be a piece of cake,
but they left feeling totally humiliated.
It probably took a few matches before word spread that this was no ordinary
princess and that men would need to train before they could even think about
challenging her.
These wrestling matches where talked about throughout Mongolia and many people
like Marco Polo traveled to see the fights Cootie Ian would show up wearing the
garment code.
Kendall,
this was usually one by men when they practice the martial arts,
but she would show up wearing a version that was made with expensive fabrics.
As soon as usually showed up wearing a similar style,
even though they were fighting,
they still showed up looking their best to the crowd.
In the year 1280 when could a human was 20 years old.
The son of King Pama arrived to try his luck in winning a match against the
princess.
The prince offered to wager a thousand horses instead of the typical 100 Marco
Polo described him as being young and incredibly good looking and he was
surrounded by an entourage of sevens when he showed up in the town and announced
that he wanted to battle acuity unit for her hand in marriage,
then women and children or showed up to witness this wrestling match and the
true,
the biggest crowds by far.
My parents were very impressed.
They thought that he was a perfect match for her and encouraged cooter unions
lose on purpose so she could marry him.
She replied that she would never lose on purpose for any amount of money.
The man who was truly worthy of a hand in marriage would win without her
throwing the match.
To his credit,
this prince lasted the longest out of any other wrestler to ever lock arms with
the princess.
Often if she slammed the brakes,
songs of the palace floor,
the sharing star buttons,
the room went silent for the first time ever.
The audience was actually disappointed that she had one since he lost it the
longest and the wrestling match of any other man,
maybe cool to une was truly considering if she should throw the match.
However,
this man was exactly the sort of husband to father would have arranged that.
If you think about it,
that does kind of defeat the purpose of her being able to choose a husband in
the first place.
[inaudible] off
the years of kicking ass and taking names,
people began to wonder why cootie you'd want it to be a single virgin for the
rest of her life.
Rumors began to spread about her in modern times.
One might assume that she was a lesbian,
was a sexual preps.
Even transgender just won't go near being one of the most progressive countries
in the world.
At that time,
they were still not accepting of homosexuality,
so it's very possible that cootie union had a strong sense of self and she
wasn't going to allow her father to force her into a marriage that would make
him miserable.
At the time,
the idea of being a lesbian,
it wasn't even an option in the minds of the public.
We're in the spread.
That kid may have even had an incestuous relationship with his daughter.
However,
this,
it's probably unlikely.
Unfortunately.
It's a rumor that we said of a lot of women back then.
It was just so out of the ordinary that the daughter was held in such high
regard by her father and that he allowed her to remain unmarried.
The situation was so odd.
People simply didn't know what to make of it.
According to a passion statesman named rash it out,
didn't go to union,
was fighting so hard for freedom because she was in love with a man named Gaza.
He was the Mongolian leader of the Persian territories and a direct descendant
of Ganga Ashcan as well.
That meant that they would have been cousins and maybe they union would have
been forbidden because they were too closely related.
Whether the theory is true on Oscoda,
you never did marry Gaza and he is remembered for converting to Islam and
setting a new precedent for future rulers.
In Modern Day Iran,
he married another princess named Coco Chin who was nicknamed the blue princess
and remembered for his stunning beauty locking in paradigm helped escort across
the desert to meet her new husband's goody.
You would have been the polar opposites if this datey frail princess.
It's possible there's a hot belonged to a man that she simply couldn't have.
We never do learn if gives a union got married,
if she remains on married,
having an affairs with men,
or if she was secretly enjoying a harm of our own.
Most historians believe that she was single for the rest of her life because a
royal wedding,
surely it would have been on the record somewhere.
What we do know though is that if she got married,
she would have never been allowed to live out her one true passion in life,
which was to be a warrior and she continued to do just that,
like the male Mongolian warriors.
If a day cooter you and participated in many battles alongside her father and
his army.
Since she was lighter than a male writer,
she was able to gallop in on a horse at faster speeds than a male counterpart.
Since she was just a strong Marco.
Polo describes a technique of galloping up to an enemy soldier on the opposite
side of the battlefields,
picking him up with just one Hanson's lifting his body off the ground while on
horseback and delivering the enemy back to her side of the battle.
She was like a hawk flying in on its prey and the enemy was understandably
terrified of her.
Can I do con Fela?
Kuti unit was the best warrior in his own.
The end,
she would have been a very capable leader.
She was even given a silver medallion cooled garagey to wear around her neck.
This is like the modern day equivalent of becoming a decorated general.
She has the only Mongolian woman to ever hold that honor and let's just
appreciate that statement for a moment.
If the Chi do to say that his daughter was the strongest warrior in his entire
Ami is a big deal.
Even in modern times,
it would be almost unheard of to see that a woman is stronger than an entire
army full of men and the Mongolians.
They were born and bred to be war machines.
Even though Chi Dukan wanted to appoint cooter unit as his successor,
putting a woman in charge was against the rules.
This was fine with you in though because she was much more at home on the
battlefields then in a diplomatic position,
despite a hesitation to take over the throne.
As a young woman,
she still attended to a thought of those courts and was present for all of their
important meetings,
so she was well aware of the local politics.
The master was dropped and all of our brothers expected that one of them would
be declared the next con.
Whenever their father passed away in the year 30 no one can kid was dying and
his dying wish was for cootie une to takeover as cotton.
Even though he had 14 sons,
none of them could possibly have been as good of a military leader into
political leaders.
His daughter,
he attempted to break all Mongolian traditions and deployment.
Cootie Yoon as is true app at this point.
Cooter Yoon was 41 years old.
She had years of experience behind her and she was respected and feared amongst
the army.
She was also old enough now to feel that she was ready to take home the role of
leader.
However,
how brothers they weren't having it.
A man named duo was given the position as the new con.
If their territory in 1306 cooter une whiskey killed,
and that is no record as to exactly how she died.
Considering that she had a following of soldiers who respected her,
it's possible that there was a power struggle and that she was killed.
Most of you may have never heard of Cooper Union until now,
and that's probably because there is very little information from people who
actually knew her logo,
Pilar and rationale din all the only two historians who around in the 12
hundreds to write down the details of her life.
And each of them only devoted one or two pages of their books to her story,
despite the fact that she was badly mentioned in these texts of the Mongolian
empire.
The story of his strength was so fascinating.
It was still passed along by both Mongolian and Chinese people.
Like simple word of mouth,
just like a childhood game of telephone.
Huh.
Story was convoluted over the years in the 17 hundreds a French writer named
Francois De de Della crew road stories from Asia for a Western audience and he
includes diversion of QT une story only in his telling,
she was a Chinese princess names tour Indo who refuses to marry a man unless he
could solve three riddles if they fail,
they die.
This story was eventually made into an Italian all opera QT you,
and I'll say briefly of heads and the Netflix series,
Marco Polo,
but it barely scraped the surface of how truly awesome she actually was.
And we hope in some way that with this video we've helped the true story of Qt
Yoon,
the warrior princess,
that volunteer.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos three times a week,
so hit that subscribe button and that notification bell if you actually want to
get notified about these videos.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.